it's no secret that all eyes are on the
russian ukraine conflict right now
people want to understand how is this
going to play out at the same time the
united states nato and our allies all
coming together and living unprecedented
economic sanctions against the country
we've kicked the russian banks out of
the swift system we've gone after
everyone from government officials to
russian oligarchs but of course the
people who bear the brunt the people who
feel the pain the most are the average
citizens right now they've seen their
wealth be degraded away as the ruble is
in a free fall their stock holdings
can't be accessed because the stock
market has been shut off due to high
volatility and on top of that if they go
to the local atm the banks have
self-imposed limits on withdrawals or
they can't actually pull enough of their
wealth out if they want to flee the
country so what we're watching here is
that we have a global payment system
that is ruled by people who monopolize
it if you do not agree with them if you
do not subscribe to their view if you do
not succumb to what they want you to do
you get cut off you get kicked out and
you can't access your wealth now of
course this brings us to the idea of
bitcoin a decentralized digital currency
and what i tweeted yesterday still
stands true bitcoin is now the only
global payment system that won't
discriminate against anyone regardless
of their race their nationality their
religion their politics or their actions
and this is going to become more and
more important in the coming decades
we can sit and debate whether somebody
did something well or not are they good
or are they evil but ultimately that is
all perspective and of course nobody
wants violent conflict but when we use
sanctions to go after these countries
we're not hurting the politicians we're
not hurting those in power what we're
doing is we're actually hurting the
average citizen and they're going to be
looking for a release valve they're
going to be looking for some way to be
able to continue to live their lives to
pursue a life of happiness and financial
security and ultimately bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies they provide that
solution hey you did you like this video
great we make five of them a day and
post them here on this channel make sure
you subscribe like the video and see you
next time